President Trump goes to Phoenix and
things get wild
ESPN decides that it has to shuttle away
some Asian American dude named Robert
Lee because they don't want to offend
people over the Confederacy and the
media does something so stupid that it
may get Trump reelected I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show okay so I
can't wait to discuss this ESPN story
because it just demonstrates why no one
is watching MSNBC with footballs ever
again
why they are dying why they deserve to
go it's really horrifying plus we'll go
through in detail president Trump's barn
burner of the speech in Phoenix Arizona
last night it was chock full of insanity
and fun and joy and weirdness it was it
was all the things that make those who
love Trump love Trump and all those who
hate Trump a Trump it was all of those
things and more and the media falls
right into his trap every single time
we'll talk about all of those things
plus my favorite video ever of a
protester and her healthy well play that
I may have to start off with that one
but before we even get to that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at helix sleep so as I've told you
a thousand times on this program I am
batted sleep but is one of the few
things in life I'm bad at I'm amazing at
everything but I suck at sleep sleep is
just not my thing until I got this helix
sleep mattress so helix sleep allows you
go on their website helix sleep calm and
you fill out their survey which is
basically which side you like to sleep
on and you sleep on your stomach or your
back do you like the mattress to be
breathable do you like to be hard or
soft and then they run it through their
proprietary algorithm and they send you
directly to your house their mattress
you take it out of the box you take it
out of the plastic and it inflates right
in front of you because it's foam and
you pop it on the bed and you're good to
go
it is supremely comfortable so
comfortable in fact that we took what is
a more expensive mattress and moved it
out of our room and moved it into the
other room you can even get mattresses
that have different settings for two
sides of the bed so for you and your
spouse if you have different if you have
different levels of firmness or softness
on the mattress that you enjoy helix
sleep will allow you to do that as well
also you have a hundred nights to try it
out if you don't like it they'll pick it
up for free and give you a 100% refund
so you have nothing to lose plus the
mattresses are less expensive then you
would have to go that you have to get if
you went to some sort of retail place
because they're cutting out the
middleman helix sleep comm /ban gets you
dollars off your first order that's
helix sleep calm slash Ben you spend at
least a third of your life on that
mattress if you're lucky more so helix
leap calm slash button makes sure they
get that 50% discount off your order
again helix sleep dot-com slash pen use
that slash pens that they know that we
sent you and they continue to advertise
with us ok so there's so many great
stories today to get to I think I'm
gonna have to start with this story from
ESPN because it's so insane so ESPN
yesterday announced that they're
broadcasting some college football game
from the University of Virginia now as I
recall the situation in Charlottesville
happened at the University of Virginia
campus in Charlottesville and so they
were going to broadcast this game this
football game University of Virginia and
one of the announcers names is an Asian
guy named Robert Lee that's the name of
one of the announcers ESPN announced
that they would not allow Robert Lee to
announce the game because his name is
Robert is like robert e lee and they
were afraid people might be offended by
his name no i am not joking
he's an asian guy named robert lee okay
like the you might be able to tell these
two people apart this is fifteen okay
you might be able to tell these two
people apart robert e lee and robert lee
okay you might you might actually be
able to see the difference between them
it's it's rather striking they do not
look the same in any way because um yeah
yeah if you get these two mixed up it's
because you're stupid first of all i
think the great mistake here by ESPN is
assuming the college students know who
Robert E Lee is they have no clue who
robert e lee is but in any case the idea
that we can't have a guy named robert
lee an Asian guy announced a football
game because he has the same name as
robert e lee is totally insane it's
totally and say but demonstrative of why
people have stopped watching ESPN
because ESPN this not all people ESPN
has a lot of challenges from online from
the fact that you can see clips of your
favorite games without having to watch
through an hour of SportsCenter like you
did when i was a kid but one of the
reasons that ESPN is losing viewers is
because they are so damn politically
correct and this is just another piece
of that puzzle
ESPN released a statement from
Appomattox Courthouse apparently they
said we collectively made the decision
with Roberts to switch games as the
tragic events in Charlottesville were
unfolding
simply because of the coincidence of his
name in that moment it felt right to all
parties it's a shame that this is
a topic of conversation we regret that
who calls play-by-play for a football
game has become an issue and then an
ESPN executive cents a piece of mail to
Yasha Ali of New York Magazine I said
this wasn't about offending anyone it
was about the reasonable possibility
that because of his name he would be
subjected to memes and jokes and who
knows what else
think about it Robert Lee comes to town
to a game in Charlottesville the
reaction to our switching a young
anonymous play-by-play guy first a
streamed ACC game is off the charts
reasonable proof that the meme joke
possibility was real okay fine so there
were gonna be some memes and jokes who
cares it would have been funny I calm
down everyone and wasn't like Asian
announcer of college football Robert Lee
was coming to town because he wanted to
re-enslave all the black people like
that's that that wasn't a thing and they
said when the protest in Charlottesville
were happened and we raised with him the
notion of switching games something we
do all the time we didn't make him we
asked him eventually mutually agreed to
the switch
no biggie until someone leaked it to
embarrass us in him they got their way
that's what happened no politically
correct efforts no race issues just
trying to be supportive of a young guy
who felt it best to avoid the potential
zoo or alternatively ESPN went to him
they say that they initiated it said we
raised the possibility with him so
they're trying to blame it on Robert Lee
but Robert Lee would have none of it he
deployed Stonewall Jackson his agents to
argue with them and when that failed he
tried Pickett's Charge that didn't work
either and eventually he was moved off
the Charlottesville Virginia game it's
just insane I love that the left has
been saying president Trump is totally
crazy when he says that we would want to
remove things like George Washington
statues or Thomas Jefferson statues how
dare how dare Donald Trump suggest that
we would go overboard with this stuff
you just ban an Asian guy named Robert
Lee from announcing a game in
Charlottesville because he has the same
name as robert e lee it was almost as
stupid in fact i think it's even dumber
then there the oregon school board wants
to remove the name lynch from various
buildings because they're named after
people whose last name is lynch not
after lynching but they think it might
be offensive you know who else would be
offended by this maybe like Loretta
Lynch the black former attorney general
under Barack Obama or Marshawn Lynch the
black running back for the Seattle
Seahawks but apparently we're now so
stupid that we can't tell the difference
between this dude and this dude we can't
tell the difference between Robert Lee
and Robert Ely even though they live too
centuries apart and look nothing like
one another and do not share an
ethnicity or apparently a middle initial
so pretty amazing work ESPN the same
network that tells you the Caitlyn
Jenner is the apotheosis of heroism
Caitlyn Jenner who has not been
athletically relevant since before I was
born and gushed over Colin Kaepernick
and spent time saying how Colin
Kaepernick must must must be put on the
playing field and they had several
announcers this week suggest the
national anthem just shouldn't be played
a game so the black people in the NFL
wouldn't have the burden of trying to
kneel during the anthem you wonder why
people are tuning out your network it's
because you're all morons that's that's
why they're tuning out your network okay
so with that is backdrop we can now
discuss President Trump speech in
Phoenix you wonder why things are so
politicized it's because the nitpicking
the stupidity the minor point making on
both sides has just reached epic fever
pitch and it really is amazing and
horrifying so Trump goes to Phoenix to
speak and there's a lot of hubbub in the
streets about Trump speaking some
protesters show up to to yell at the
people who are coming in and they get
violent and they get terrible I do want
to show you one clip of the this is the
greatest clip of a protester I've ever
seen this is one protester who decides
to kick a gas canister back at the at
the police officers and things go wildly
wrong from this clip 9 this is pretty
pretty amazing stuff I will never get
over loving this
[Applause]
[Music]
now he goes down he goes and there does
Buick a predict Jersey doing better
blocking or I think Colin Kapernick in
seven years
I'm sorry we're gonna need to see that
again because it was just too wonderful
[Music]
okay I have an army full of loyal
listeners who like making videos like
this okay I need someone to I need
someone to cut a video of this with the
music with it with the I can remember
the the name of the song is I will
always love you I need any Ton Ton and
then right as it hits him in the crotch
I need and I will always love you
that's what I need I need that so if you
do that I'll tweet it out because that
will be amazing thanks guys okay so I
just had to show that because a little
light-hearted revelry never hurt anyone
except right in the balls so that pretty
pretty spectacular Trump is speaking
inside the arena and in his speech is
Wow
General John Kelly General John Kelly
was the guy whose Trump's new chief of
staff and he's got to be like Tommen
from Game of Thrones at this point just
like walking over to that window and
taking a header because my goodness my
goodness he was supposed to have Trump
under control Trump gives what I thought
was quite a good speech on Afghanistan I
critique - yesterday on the program I
talked at length about why I thought
that Trump was doing a lot of the right
things in Afghanistan and then Trump was
like you know what I can't look like I
know what I'm doing
boom and then he goes to Phoenix and he
just starts ranting now what's amazing
is that the media will always pull
Trump's chestnuts out of the fire no
matter what Trump does the media will
always do something stupid or it's it's
just a call it the Shapiro law of the
media no matter what Trump does the
media will do something dumber that
eventually forces people right back into
Trump's corner and that's sort of what
happened yesterday so I want to get to
all of that but before I do I first want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
quip so there are a lot of recent
studies suggesting that if you have good
oral health that impact
your overall health and if you have
plaque on your teeth that may lead to
plaque in your heart you may have higher
rates of heart disease this is why I use
quip quip is a new company refreshing
the way people brush their teeth it's an
electronic toothbrush an electric
toothbrush the packs premium vibration
and timer features into an ultra slim
design it's not one of those things
where it carry it around it's like eight
pounds it really is slim it feels just
like a regular toothbrush it's battery
power
it's like Apple designed a toothbrush
but without the big price tag you can
subscribe to quip and receive a new
brush head on a dentist recommended
three month plan for just five dollars
including free shipping which is awesome
too because very often I've had an
electric toothbrush for a while but you
forget when to replace the actual brush
head so you're now three years into that
brush head that was supposed to last you
three months and you're brushing your
teeth with all of your old plaque quick
prevents that by actually sending you a
new brush head every three months when
you when you pay five dollars that's the
that's the dentist recommended plan they
are backed by leading dentists and they
were named as Time Magazine's best
inventions of 2016 right now go to get
quick comm slash capiro get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush that is quick get quick calm
GE tqu IP comm / Shapiro you can also
take it on the road unlike a lot of
other electric toothbrushes where you
actually have to bring the charger with
you and it's really heavy this thing is
all self-contained and so you just bring
it with you whenever you're traveling
keeps your teeth a lot cleaner you feel
a lot fresher get quick calm / Shapiro
and with that / capiro you get your
first refill pack absolutely free with
the quip electric toothbrush I love this
product I use it morning and evening it
is fantastic brush your teeth twice a
day people it's good oral hygiene and
use clip to do it get quick calm /
Shapiro's go ahead and check it out okay
so now we finally get to the drama and
the wonder of this Trump speech in
Phoenix so Trump starts off and he's on
teleprompter and the amusing thing about
President Trump is you can certainly
tell when he's off teleprompter because
the difference between Trump on
teleprompter and Trump off teleprompter
is stark and amazing so here's Trump on
teleprompter talking about the lourve
right he's doing the routine that all
these presidents do Bush did it Obama
did it how mine is a movement of lurve
it's love people love like my love you
de ing Lu ving
I love it go our movement is a movement
built on love it's love for fellow
citizens it's love for struggling
Americans who've been left behind it's
built unloved you understand love except
for the media they are evil and I wish
that a steamroller would run them over
just like at the end of Roger Rabbit
paper you remember that the judge gets
rolled over and then he'd been flat and
then his eyes pop out it's all creepy
and I wish that the steamroller would do
that too like Jake Tapper he's the worst
I hate these paper paper paper okay here
he goes talking about all the people he
doesn't learn what happened in Charlotte
stone strikes at the core of America on
teleprompter night this entire arena
stands United in forceful condemnation
of the thugs who perpetrate hatred and
violence but the very dishonest media
those people right up there with all the
cameras off and I mean truly dishonest
people in the media and the fake media
they make up stories they have no
sources in many cases they say a source
says there is no such thing but they
don't report the facts just like they
don't want to report that I spoke out
forcefully against hatred bigotry and
violence and strongly condemned the neon
the white supremacist and the KKK
okay so Trump now feels the need to
relitigate his entire charlottesville
response which again is really stupid
politics he just did a mean he this is
now the third time second time this is
the second time he has now swiveled back
on the Charlottesville response so he
gave the proper Charlottesville response
a week ago yesterday right it was he
gave it on the Monday before last Monday
he gave his the proper Charlottesville
response which was the statement about
white supremacist and the KKK and
neo-nazis and the next day did his crazy
press conference where he talked about
what is the outright I don't know does
anyone know who knows how to spell it
and then he did the routine about very
Italian people right you remember he did
all of this and then on Monday he did
his speech about Afghanistan were like
okay we're done with this okay we can
move on with the news cycle but no now
in Phoenix he feels the needs to
relitigate this and he related get it
dishonestly okay I'm just gonna be
honest about this the way that Trump
relitigated this thing is he read his
original statement but he left off the
key word so he said that he had
condemned the egregious display of
hatred bigotry and violence here is
Trump trying to rehash this case but he
leaves off a few key words it's cuz you
know where my heart is okay I'm really
doing this to show you how damn
dishonest these people are so here is my
first statement when I heard about
Charlottesville and I have a home in
Charlotte for a lot of people don't know
here's the first can't believe they
haven't figured that one out yet now
they know now they finally know but I
just I don't want to bore you with this
but it shows you how dishonest they are
and most of you know this anyway so
here's what I said
really fast here's what I said on
Saturday we're closely following the
terrible events unfolding in
Charlottesville Virginia this is me
speaking we condemn in the strongest
possible terms this egregious display of
hatred bigotry and violence okay and
then he stopped there do you remember
what he said next in his original press
conference he said on many sides and
many said that was the entire
controversy legitimately the entire
controversy with words that he just
failed to read from the piece of paper
so he's relitigated this and the purpose
of Hemery litigating this is because not
a lot really unifies the Republican
Party at this point there are
disagreements over foreign policy on
Afghanistan there are disagreements on
immigration there disagreements on taxes
there disagreements on infrastructure
there's disagreements on reconciliation
versus versus attempting to ram through
bills without reconciliation there are
disagreements on virtually every issue
Under the Sun but there is not a lot of
disagreement on the right side of the
aisle of the media sock and the reason
that people think the media suck is
because they respond emotionally to
everything they respond emotion is
really going he decided to make the
focus of this speech attacks on the
media and attacks on an Tifa to things
that the Republicans and conservatives
rightly disliked okay here is Trump
going after an Tifa is pretty
spectacular actually you know they show
up in the helmets and the black masks
and they've got clubs and they've got
everything and Tifa and Tifa okay you
know I was gonna do it in things I liked
but now I'm just gonna have to take a
swift break here and into it now this
cannot be be this is this is president
Trump's ante foe song
[Music]
the hell
[Laughter]
yes well done well done okay so back to
the speech to just read and see if he's
ripping on the media and then he starts
talking about how he's more elite than
the media which this is what his people
love about him is they dislike the media
so much that anybody who will just
insult the media for the purpose of
insulting the media is worthwhile so
here's Trump talking about how he was a
good student hint no evidence of this
and then he talks about how he has the
nicer houses than any of the people in
the media pretty amazing stuff you know
I was a good student I always hear about
the elite you know the elite merrily I
went to better schools than they did I
was a better student than they were I
live in a bigger more beautiful
apartment and I live in the white house
too which is really great I think you
know what I think where the elites
they're not the elites that's what I
think what what do you think guys are
they the elites at Hamburg's like wait a
second you've been ripping on the elites
for like years well what now it's like
but I don't care because poop on them
you see poop it comes out of your butt
right on them okay and then he goes even
further then he gets to the real meat of
matter he gets angry and he starts
talking about the media throughout this
speech he keeps saying that the media
are turning off the cameras he keeps
saying oh in the back they're turning
off the cameras they won't show the
crowd he says CNN cut up CNN cut off the
cameras people are watching him say this
on CNN okay so clearly not true and then
he's saying they won't show the crowds
every feet is showing the crowd every
single one so either but people on my
side you know people on the right we
don't care about that because we think
the media are dishonest and as I will
say the Shapiro rule will begin to apply
in just a moment because I'll show you
how the media blew this wide open in
ridiculous fashion but here is Trump
saying the media are unpatriotic these
are really really dishonest people and
they're bad people and I really think
they don't like our country I really
believe that and I don't believe they're
gonna change and that's why I do this if
they would change I would never say it
the only people giving a platform to
these hate groups is
Media itself in the fake news oh that's
so funny look back there the live red
lights that turning those suckers off
fast nothing okay except that they
weren't this is all the people laughing
and cheering on so truly none of it was
true
okay and then he talked about his
favorite media outlets right so of
course of course hehe see this is what
so stupid is that I think that there are
people at Fox who are trying to do a
good job in covering the president it
doesn't help them when the president
endorses them any more than it would
have helped MSNBC for Barack Obama to
endorse their coverage if you think that
Fox is doing a good job mr. president
Shh but no he feels the need to talk
about Fox and Fox is treating him fairly
but everyone else is very mean to him
and who are the fairest of all the
fairest people you guys did Sean Hannity
you have some great networks I must tell
you
Fox has treated me fairly
they've treated me fairly
hey I'll let you know you know what
someday they might not treat me fairly
and I'll tell you about it okay
but they've treated me fairly and I
don't mean all good I get plenty of bad
on fox too but at least it's within
reason and Hannity how good is Hannity
he say is the Trump speaks with Kennedy
almost every evening that is that is a
ongoing rumor in sort of media circles
okay so all of this is is to say that
Trump is now trying for a punch the
media because number one he feels that
the media is unfair to him but number
two because he understands the way
unifies the Republican Party right now
is not policy it's not him it's not the
Congress what unifies him is this
oppositional feel toward the media now
the thing is that Trump actually did
make some news in this speech it wasn't
just him railing against the media in
typical trumpian fashion for half an
hour he actually made some news in the
middle of the speech for example he
dumped the news that he was basically
gonna pardon Sheriff Joe Arpaio who
shouldn't be pardoned Sheriff Joe is the
the sheriff down in Maricopa County very
colorful guy he was famous for
addressing all of the inmates in pink
there was a restraining order that was
put out against him suggesting he was
engaging in racial profiling he did not
believe he was engaging in racial
profiling so he kept doing what he was
doing
so they jailed him for violation of a
court order and Trump is saying that
he's gonna pardon him but he had said
beforehand before the speech that he
wasn't gonna pardon him in front of the
crowd but then he basically said that he
was gonna pardon him in front of the
crowd do the people in this room like
Sheriff Joe was Sheriff Joe convicted
for doing his job
that's what
he should have had a jury but you know
what I'll make a prediction I think he's
gonna be just fine okay
lose Wow that's actual news okay and
then he make some more actual nose he
says that when it comes to the border
wall he's willing to he's willing to
check out he's willing to countenance a
government shutdown in order to get his
border wall and we are building a wall
on the southern border which is
absolutely necessary build that wall now
the obstructionist democrats would like
us not to do it but believe me we have
to close down our government we're
building that wall okay so this is all
news there's other news that he made he
talked about getting rid of the
filibuster rule he talked about how he
was ripping on Jeff Flake and John
McCain not by name not by name but he
was ripping on all of these people and
then he talked about how he's gonna
terminate NAFTA so there was an actual
news chamber it was the media's response
that was really astonishing and I'm
gonna talk about the media response in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at USC CA
so two years ago there's a guy named
Steve Maddox and he was attacked by a
300-pound dude it took four grown men
just to pull him off but the man was
attacked again and Steve quickly
realized the only thing that was going
to stop the attacker was a bullet but
after defending himself he was the guy
who got arrested sources are now
reporting that after two years a
grueling trial and hundreds of thousands
of dollars Steve was finally able to
prove his innocence innocence that an
overzealous anti-gun da tried to take
away from him because if Steve hadn't
been able to afford a good attorney he
wouldn't just be facing a lifetime in
prison but a lifetime of financial ruin
and that's where USC CA comes in for as
little as $13 a month they'll have the
legal and financial protection that you
need should you ever find yourself in
Steve's shoes having to use a weapon to
protect yourself right now when you
activate your membership you'll be
entered to win a new gun so if you need
to protect yourself you need a gun and
you also need the you need the resources
that come after you have to fire the gun
you need to go over to defend my family
now calm let's defend my family now calm
to see how the USC CA can protect you
and your family they offer a wide range
of services from education to legal
protection
again that's defend my family now calm
defend my family now calm and you will
be entered to win a new gun when you
register and defend my family now calm
so I'm just to finish up with presidents
from
speech in Phoenix before we get to the
insane meteor response you know
President Trump also talked about Jeff
Flake he talked about John McCain so
here he is talking not not the
filibuster rule one will do the next one
he talked about how how he didn't want
to mention any names but clearly he
means John McCain here as far as Obama
care being being maintained one one one
vote away you can hear the crowd
shouting McCain's name we were one vote
away think of it seven years the
Republicans and again you have some
great senators but we have one vote away
from repeal but you know they all said
mr. president your speech was so good
last night
please please mr. president don't
mention any names so I won't I won't
this is hilarious all of his advisers
like John Kelly right now it's not oh my
god I told him not to do this and here
he is attacking senators in his own
party Arizona is a purple state now okay
there are Democrats who get elected in
Arizona if Jeff Flake or John McCain
were to go down if they were to go down
to some sort of primary challenge and
then they were to lose the seat that
would be on Trump okay that's not to say
there aren't decent candidates in
Arizona there may very well be but this
attack on his own party is pretty
astonishing actually so all of this is
news all this is news but the media find
a way to blow it and I'm gonna talk
about that in just a second but for that
you're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire calm and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you too can get your subscription
today Lee Weyer watch this show live in
its entirety and later when we post it
watch it without ads you can watch
Andrew clavin's show in its entirety at
10:30 a.m. Pacific time you can watch
Michael Moses show in its entirety at
12:30 Pacific time so we have lots of
great material for you over at daily
wire plus you get the website ad freeze
that's pretty awesome as well also if
you get the annual subscription then you
get this the very finest in all of
drinking drink where it's a leftist
year's hot or cold tumbler you will
enjoy it I promise I don't want to
I don't want to just you know gosh on
and on about this thing is I have
everyday for a month but let's just say
that it will change your life in a
variety of amazing ways
the leftist year's hot or cold tumblr
you get that with your $99 annual
subscription see save off the monthly
subscription as well or if you just want
to listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe leave a review we
always do appreciate it it helps us with
the iTunes ranking when you leave a
review as well so please make sure to do
that we are the largest and fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
okay so the media could cover Trump's
rally in a variety of ways they could
report the news from it the stuff about
NAFTA the stuff about the government
shutdown they could report all of the
things that he said that our material
instead the media fall right into
Trump's trap because Trump's entire trap
is this
he tells Americans hey guys the media
the very mean to me they're very unfair
they like other time they have a hatred
they hate you they hate me
they hate America they hate so what he's
really saying is the media are an
emotional machine dedicated to my
destruction
what would the media need to do to
counter that well they would need to act
in dispassionate fashion they would need
to go on TV and say you know president
Trump came to speech tonight very
well-received by his crowd here are the
things he said that are factually untrue
and then just ticked them off okay
they're a bunch of them like in the
middle of the speech Trump said
something about how clean coal is about
taking coal and cleaning it which
doesn't even make any sense how do you
clean coal okay clean coal is about
finding new methods of mining that are
actually that are cleaner for the
environment but the media instead of
critiquing the factual points in Trump
speech or saying you know President
Trump is attacking the media because
he's attempting to distract but here is
what the real agenda was in this
particular speech instead of doing that
the media just decided to go absolutely
not so Don Lemon on CNN he he had a
segment last night with Anna Navarro in
which they basically sat around talking
about how Trump was crazy how Trump was
a nut and Don Lemon did a monologue last
night immediately following the speech
in which he ripped president Trump up
and down talked about how President
Trump was obviously unqualified how he
was trying to start a civil war this of
course plays right into Trump's hands
because his entire base believes that
the media re out to get Trump and so the
more you act like this the more you tell
his base that you're that they're right
and how about the people who are in the
middle the people who are in the middle
just see a slap fight
they don't necessarily side with Don
Lemon over Trump and they don't
necessarily side with Trump overs on
lemon but they look at this and they go
Trump slapping the media the media look
like they're slapping him back it looks
like just it looks like a clown fight it
looks like it looks like you know an old
an old boxing match between a couple of
300-pound ladies I mean that that's what
that's what this looks like so here's
Don Lemon slapping at Trump in a way
that actually helps Trump he's on
hinged it's embarrassing and I don't
mean for us the media because he went
after us but for the country this is who
we elected president of the United
States a man who is so pitted petty that
he has to go after people who he deems
to be his enemy like an imaginary friend
of a six-year-old his speech was without
thought it was without reason it was
devoid of facts it was devoid of wisdom
there was no gravitas there was no
sanity there he was like a child blaming
a sibling on something else he did it I
didn't do it
he certainly opened up the race wound
from Charlottesville a man clearly
wounded by the rational people who are
abandoning him in droves meaning those
business people and the people in
Washington now who are questioning his
fitness for office and whether he is
stable like journalism or advocacy
does that help Trump or does it hurt him
is my view that this helps Trump that
trumps entire narrative is that the
media are out to get him and when Don
Lemon says all the stuff and I'm sure
Don Lemon feels all the stuff when he
says all this stuff all it does is it
grants credence to Trump's argument that
this is an emotional response because
again dispassionate analysis should be
one thing that's not what you got from
the media last night lawrence O'Donnell
on MSNBC actually cut into the speech in
order to say the Trump is lying about
the media if they're doing a story about
me I know if it's honest or false this
is the president lying about the media
he is telling his audience that the
media lies about him
the president just quoted his remarks on
Saturday after Charlottesville and he
falsely quoted his remarks he said on
that Saturday we condemn in the
strongest possible terms this egregious
display of hatred bigotry and violence
on many sides on many sides he repeated
that twice he did not include that just
now in his quoting of himself to this
audience he is lying to this audience
about what he said and he is lying to
this audience about what the media said
about what he said okay the nature of
media the nature of TV is that your
emotions come across even more than your
words and it's obvious that lawrence
O'Donnell is very pissed but is he
pissed because Trump is lying or is he
pissed
because Trump is lying about the media
Helu Italy because the lie that he just
said that Trump told was not aligned
necessarily about the media was about
what Trump himself said what it feels
like and this is one media go wrong
the media's entire their entire reason
for being is to defend the interests of
the American people is to defend the
transparency of an administration is to
bring truth to the people if the media
feel that they themselves are insulted
that's irrelevant to the question okay
the media are supposed to be sort of
like a pastor in a church they're
supposed to bring you truth that's
supposedly the goal of the media that's
their self stated goal what would happen
if you insulted the pastor in your
church
well it would be one thing if you
insulted the pastor and he said listen
and insult on me is an attack on this
particular institution and you know if
you're attacking me personally I can
take it but obviously I feel like I need
to speak the truth anyway but if the
pastor gets angry because you're
attacking him personally you might think
that he's an ego test well when you look
at the media it seems as though they are
full of people who are just focused on
Trump's dislike for them personally
Trump wants to make this personal that's
his entire goal is to make this personal
and when the media allowed this to
become a personal slap fight between
them and Trump Trump wins Trump wins
because he's the one with the base media
don't have a base like Trump's base is
bigger than Lawrence whoa Donald's are
down down lemons the idea that them
going out there and ripping Trump up and
down on character grounds for attack in
the media it's just bad strategy put
aside the truth or untruth it's just bad
strategy by the media and they are
falling right into Trump's trap see
they're not the only ones by the way
former Obama officials did James clapper
a guy who lied in front of Congress
about the nature of the government's
surveillance efforts he goes on CNN and
he says that that Trump is a national
security threat you have you said you
questioned his his fitness is he a
threat to national security the
president well he certainly could be
again having some understanding of of
the the levers that a president can
exercise I worry about frankly you know
the access to nuclear codes the in a fit
of pique he decides to do something
about Kim Jungman there is actually very
little to to stop him you know
the Trump has done anything like this on
policy there's there's the sense that he
says crazy things all the time which is
true but again bringing on James clapper
and Obama official to call Trump
unhinged is not smart politics it's also
unfair and it's and it's it's sort of
derogatory toward people who have actual
mental illness like this idea that Trump
is it deeply mentally ill a human being
who can't be trusted with the nuclear
codes listen I didn't vote for Trump but
this is over the top it is over the top
stuff and it's not helpful to anyone the
cecilia Vega is a journalist who was on
Good Morning America and she said this
was in citement pure and simple that's
what she said she said this was
incitement to violence okay this was not
incitement to violence by President
Trump we all need to get over this I
didn't think it was incitement when
Bernie Sanders suggested that Medicare
was going to that trumps cuts to
Medicaid we're going to kill people I
don't think that's incitement I think
it's stupid I don't think it's
incitement when Trump says journalists
aren't patriotic I think it's dumb but
it's not incitement the media and the
Democrats attempts to club from to death
over these sorts of comments and to
suggest that he is unfit for office
based on comments like this you know all
you're really doing is you're
reinforcing his base of support who feel
like he's under attack anyway okay and
then how much attention to the media
actually pay to the riots that were
happening outside so right after this
rally happens Trump mentioned an T font
on and on and then there are actual
riots outside from an tyfa so here's
some of the footage Trump some words in
this truck
some guy runs up hunches okay so they're
just delightful folks there it the
police were firing gas canisters at the
NT file last night police firing
flashbangs now
this again lends credence to what I've
been saying what Trump has been saying
this is the one thing I think from got
right over the past week is labeling an
Tifa a group that is ensconce tanned and
meshed in violence like we're concerned
that an tyfa is going to show up at the
speech that i'm gonna give at Berkeley
on September 14th by the way I'm
encouraging all the people you know who
are who are saying they're gonna show up
in self-defense 25 please do not show up
ready to do battle with an Tifa it is
the police's job to take care of this
this is a good object lesson okay yeah
young America's Foundation they're gonna
spend $15,000 $16,000 on extra security
mandated by UC Berkeley okay let's watch
the police do their jobs if they don't
then we all know who to blame the UC
Berkeley administration and the and the
City Police and the and the city
government will know who to blame so
please don't get involved in these in
infighting and Tifa it doesn't do
anybody any good
let Antipa do what they're doing let the
police take care of them then if the
police won't take care of them it proves
everything we want to prove about antiva
so please all the people who are saying
they're gonna come and defend my speech
i don't need you to come and defend my
speech i need you to come and attend my
speech and i will give out the link we
have to there are 2,000 seats we should
fill all of them we want to make sure
that you can come but please don't come
quote unquote prepared for violence
because that's what the police are there
for we just paid through the nose to
ensure that the police are there if they
don't do the job they're supposed to do
it tells you everything you need to know
it's an Tifa that is promoting violence
across the country I have a a piece in
national view today talking specifically
about the left embrace of mainstream
violence and why that's the danger to
the country not some schmuck piece of
garbage white supremacists who march
with torch with torches if they act
violent they're part of the problem too
but America can survive horrible views
America can't survive violence in the
streets okay so time for some things I
like and then some things I hate and a
quick Bible talk so things I like this
week I'm doing things that are related
to blindness so and that is thanks to a
president from staring directly into the
Sun during the solar eclipse
so the yesterday we did the day of the
Triffids the best the the best movie
about the about blindness it's not
really about blindness but it's called
dark victory and at the very end of the
film there is some involved there is
some blindness Betty Davis in Humphrey
Bogart and George Brent
Humphrey
learn actually has a bit of a bit part
this is one of his earlier parts Ronald
Reagan is in the film as well he has a
small part two very charming Betty Davis
in dark victory she won an Oscar for
Best Actress for dark victory she is
terrific in the film it's kind of an old
classic romance film and it is quite
good it's about she's a she's a rich
socialite here's a little bit of the of
the preview
[Music]
or brothers now proudly
most exciting star on screen story the
lights Liars of the babies
[Music]
I've never taken orders from anyone as
long as I live I'll never take orders
from anyone I'm young and strong and
nothing can touch me darling forceful
don't you know I'm in love with you are
you afraid to burn Michael are you
afraid to die what a relief to know that
you're no better than I am
[Music]
it's a great movie to watch
it was nominated for Best for Best
Picture and she won Best Actress as well
in this okay time for some things that I
hate so Trevor Noah who as I say is in a
runnin freeway street battle for least
funny comedian in America with Amy
Schumer and the third person always
tends to vary sometimes I have said that
it is John Oliver althought I think John
Oliver is is better than that sometimes
I've said W kamau Bell who truly is an
awful comedian but Trevor Noah he did a
segment on his show last night about how
he was back in South Africa which is the
country from which he hails and he came
back and it turns out that America is
the is the third rack so now I was like
okay this is not a vacation that is
chaos but I still had a week of my break
left so I thought you know what I'm
gonna go back to America and just chill
turns out I left the third world and
landed in the Third Reich okay no you
didn't use stupid you did not land
in the Third Reich okay I promise you
see this on my head you see how I'm
sitting here doing a show you see how my
entire family is fine this is not the
third raft my friend this nonsense where
you compare America to the third raft
because President Trump says stupid crap
all the time that is just it's insane
and again you talk about the media
driving people into the arms of Trump
when you label everyone a Nazi it turns
out people get mad it turns out people
get mad it turns out that people have a
right to be angry when you suggest that
America is Nazi Germany in 2017 hey
Trevor Noah is sitting there doing a
nationally televised two TV show talking
about the Third Reich in America do you
think that Hitler allowed people to do
that
it's such stupid exaggeration it's not
even funny it's not even funny it's just
dumb okay other things that I hate so
now the Cleveland Browns are kneeling
during the national anthem look enough
is enough guys it's just your football
players it's it's ridiculous that the
big story here is that apparently one of
the guys who kneeled for the Cleveland
Browns is a white guy whoo well now it's
beginning across racial lines whoo
who cares who cares you're much for
football players whatever you have the
right to do what you're doing so I think
you're more on yes to I think you're
stupid
yes do I think that you are
disrespectful to the veterans who have
fought and died for the flag
the national anthem yes there are
unifying symbols in America that still
means something and I think it's
ridiculous that you're kneeling during
the national anthem instead of trying to
perfect the Union you are seeking to
tear it down and is it people like
frederick douglass would have agreed
with me but this is this is really
foolishness
here is a here's some of the cleveland
browns doing this routine we wanted to
draw attention to the fact that there's
things in this country that still need
to change and I myself will be raising
children that don't look like me I want
to do my part as well to do everything I
can to raise them in a better
environment than we have right now so I
want wanted to take them Kinney with my
teammates too during the anthem to pray
for our country okay do you think that
it really does the Union a favor that it
really doesn't exacerbate tensions when
you kneel during the national anthem if
you want to pray why don't you wait till
after the national anthem and then do a
team prayer and then get out to the
media that what you're praying for is a
better future for the country why do you
have to use the national anthem as the
wedge really foolish again
counterproductive well you know when the
left does this stuff they're not
achieving their goals they're actually
driving people into Trump's camp the
left keeps doing this Trump will win her
election in a landslide okay time for a
brief Bible talk so every week we go
through a little portion of the Bible
the Jews go through a different portion
of the Bible each week but we went
through the entire Bible last year so
this year we are going through these
sections of the prophets and the
writings that correspond to the portion
of the Bible that we read every week so
this week we read from Isaiah 52 now
we've just entered the month of elavil
the month of LL is considered that we
were getting close to the Days of Awe
the the lead-up to Rosh Hashanah the
beginning of the Jewish New Year and a
Yom Kippur which is the holiest day on
the Jewish calendar this is the period
of time where Jews do their repentance
for all of the things they've sinned for
over the last year and so we read a lot
of literature that sort of about us
returning to God this is from Isaiah 52
verses 8 through 10 the voice of your
Watchmen they raised a voice together
they shall sing for eye to eye they
shall see when the Lord returns to Zion
burst out in song sing together a ruins
of Jerusalem for the Lord has consoled
his people he has redeemed Jerusalem the
Lord has revealed his holy arm before
the eyes of all the nations and all the
ends of the earth shall see the
salvation
our God so I'm focusing on that second
verse for a second part where it says
burst out in song sync together Oh ruins
of Jerusalem there's a very famous story
in the Talmud that it's famous for Jews
anyway and Tomic well rabbi akiva Rabbi
Akiva is a very famous rabbi in Jewish
history part of the Bar Kokhba revolt
against Roman rule was killed for his
participation in that revolt but Rabbi
Akiva and a bunch of rabbis were
supposedly walking through the ruins of
the Second Temple after the destruction
of the simple Second Temple and they
were seeing animals run through the the
ruins of Jerusalem the ruins of the
temple and all the other rabbis were
crying and Rabbi Akiva starts laughing
and so all of his friends turn in and
they say ya rabbi akiva what's going on
why are you laughing
and he says I'm laughing because the
same prophecy that says that the temple
will be destroyed also says that the
temple will be rebuilt and I have faith
that it will be rebuilt the same is true
for the United States and Western
civilization I don't think that what
we're watching right now the decay of
Western civilization the decay of
America is permanent I think there can
be renewal I think there can be a
restoration but it requires work we can
have faith in the restoration if we take
a hands in it we cannot have faith in
the restoration if we fail to take a
hand and if we sit around doing nothing
and simply lamenting our fate it's
important that we all take a hand in
educating our children to believe in a
better America that we stand up and tell
the truth
when we see something wrong happening
that we stand together in the face of
stupidity
and in the face of political
polarization for political purposes that
all has to end then we too can be part
of a restoration because that's the
restoration that was promised by the
founders you know the things may have
been flow in the United States but
overall America has gotten better
America can continue to get better but
only if we stand against random divisive
nests
purposes of political gain if we don't
do that then we're doomed to watch the
ruins grow around us
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all the latest breaking news I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
you